a long court fight could be on the way
over a constitutional amendment that
seemed to have died back in the 1980s
Virginia is on the brink of becoming the
38th state to pass the Equal Rights
Amendment that's intended to outlaw
discrimination against women after both
state houses passed landmark legislation
now most of those 38 states approved the
ER a more than forty years ago but it
never received the 3/4 majority needed
to become a full amendment in the past
three years legislatures in Nevada
Illinois and now Virginia appear to be
giving the ER a new life Jen Crawford is
on Capitol Hill for us Jen good morning
so what our supporter is hoping for with
this new vote I mean they're hoping that
it will be a trigger that will
eventually add the Equal Rights
Amendment to the Constitution as you
said most people thought that fight was
long over when the necessary number of
states failed to approve it before that
1982 congressional deadline now they're
hoping that if it gets to this point
courts will let them ignore that
original deadline for the women of
Virginia and the women of America the
resolution has finally these votes
Wednesday in the Virginia House Senate
joint resolution one is agreed to Senate
were celebrated as a possible turning
point by a re supporters like Donna
grants key who's been fighting for the
amendments is the 1970s the only way
that we can guarantee gender equality is
for it to be enshrined in the United
States Constitution that's what today
means to me the fight over the ER a
started in 1972 after Congress approved
language that if passed by three-fourths
of state legislatures would amend the
Constitution to guarantee that rights
under the law shall not be denied or
abridged on account of sex with support
from high-profile Republicans like first
lady Betty Ford
and large demonstrations by supporters
of the women's movement 35 are the
required 38 states passed the amendment
in just five years but the efforts
stalled when conservative lawyer Phyllis
Schlafly launched an anti er a movement
and you've got to be kidding
to say we should support something that
would require our daughters to be in
combat in the next war a 1982 deadline
for ratifying the e ra came and went and
the effort appeared over the chyme
strike at midnight for ratification of
the Equal Rights Amendment at that
moment the e ra becomes DOA now more
than four decades later supporters have
revived the amendment but opponents like
Ann chef liquori say her mother's
arguments remain valid it will cause
harms to women in all kinds of other
areas without giving them any benefit in
Virginia supporters made the fight about
the next generation it was just very
late empowering to see it get passed and
that to see that I could have an equal
future now the measure in Virginia has
yet to clear another set of votes and
then people say that a new fight then
will start I mean supporters are going
to have to go to court and argue that
that original 1982 deadline is not
binding and they should get to count the
35 states that passed it before 1982 to
get to the magic number of 38 states
needed to change the constitution
Anthony remarkable this battle is still
going on Jen thank you
you